like a lady in the Koran that's just
turning into something else I'm kind of
a craft failure my favorite pin is
lasagna soup because you can just like
throw a straw in there and like slurp it
down which is great i wing everything in
life and and love so I think today it's
gonna come together I have two daughters
I have a seven-year-old son I have a
little baby boy whose name is Dylan and
here's ten months old and I'm very
obsessed with him we are going to make
hot dogs spaghetti I'm gonna kick it up
a notch and I'm gonna do the octopus
yeah I've never manipulated a hot dog oh
yeah please look at this behold the
engineering feat this is so incredible
I'm very proud and I will eat this hands
up hands up hot dogs down Wow Wow the
boiling process is very democratizing
[Music]
it's very burping
this is Petrus oh god I'm nervous
I'm starting with a single color and
then my plan is every inch or so to add
another a little bit of white to make it
another lip level later I kind of
already give up how are you making it so
like every layer then I add more white
the wars this looks like something that
like like one would receive rations in I
use Pinterest everyday for meal
inspiration quick easy activities to get
through the witching hour with the kids
I'd pin a lot of like home decor we're
gonna do crayon and blow-dry art it's
one of the first pins that I ever saw on
Pinterest thought like really stuck out
to me and I've been wanting to try for
years I can't imagine this endure in my
house or lights I'm just kind of going
for it we're trying that's like you know
just giving it a whirl not gonna work
this is a photo well I can't even
I think it's really great I think ever
needs to know the things feel I see a
great hot dog bomb out of Ebony it's
gonna be me I'm gonna win I'm gonna do
it
you're gonna win it gonna win it all
that's good I'm so slapdash and I don't
care about their age you embraced the
like mmm loose rule let's be honest